قال عبد الرزاقها عوض مدير منظمه سيريا
ريليف في لقاء مع الجزيره انهم بداوا
مرحله جديده تتمثل في البحث عن ايواء مؤقت
لمنكوبيه الزلزال في انتظار لمرحله
الثالثه المتمثله في بناء مساكننا دائمه
للمتضررين
اليوم انتقلنا مع الفرق الانقاذ والفرقيه
انتقلت بشكل عام الى مرحله جديده هي مرحله
التفكير الجدي في ايواء في اماكن ايواء
العوائل في الحقيقه قضينا الاسبوع الماضي
باكمله مع العوائل تحت اشجار الزيتون وفي
الاماكن اللواء المؤقته وفي الخيام
المتناثره هنا وهناك
محاولين ان نسد احتياجاتهم الضروريه لكن
اليوم سننتقل الى مرحله جديده هي مرحله
التفكير في ايواءهم المؤقت لمده لا تقل عن
سته اشهر ريثما نفكر في مرحله ثالثه الا
وهي البناء بناء الغرف او المنازل
المتضرره لهؤلاء العوائل الذين فقدوا
منازلهم اما بشكل كلي او بشكل جزئي اما
اليوم فبدانا جديا في مرحله المرحله
الثانيه من الاغاثه وهي مرحله الايواء
المؤقت الفردي لهؤلاء العوائل
ولا اخفيك ان هذه المرحله هي مرحله صعبه
جدا